okay so you could answer this however
you want okay all right
the question for today is oh that's a
very good question um damn that's hard I
don't know I'm sorry I mean like I know
but like I don't know how to answer it I
don't know how to answer that one I
really don't you oh that's a very good
question um I'm actually a psychiatrist
here in Boston
hmm okay so I'm a professional choosing
to not to work for a while and traveling
around the world
I think that's yeah that's describes how
I am today
I am an old soul who became much younger
once I lived on this earth for 60-some
years
Who am I
Who am I I am a fellow human being
Southern California I'm Laura Jennings
we raise cattle and
I am a mom had a wife and hopefully a
good person that cares about the world
and wants to help other people and I
love children and it's very important to
me the children stay alive and have a
good life and know that their life can
be good and that they can make it good
no matter what happens
Who am I I am Who I am and that's all
that I am said Popeye the sailorman
[Applause]
so try to kind of figure that out
okay i'm i'm russian student i am a
musician who is working as hard as he
can to achieve his goals how he could
bring you to the phone dance like this
you don't talk about dancing you don't
talk you don't so i am a woman and I am
also Hispanic I am passionate I
over a nice person Who am I
whoo Oh Aaron the pencil you perceive me
though I mean that's the thing that Who
am I
according to me over in my life on that
perceives hmm I'm a human being most of
all think of the first one I'm a human
being and then from that I think that
that into what is specifically I'm a
human being
I am Who am I noun adjective or verb I
am a queen in action I am a woman of God
I'm wonderfully and fearfully made in
His image and power to do all things
that I put my mind to I am machete I am
25 years old I am in Saudi Arabia I like
it you're saying who are you my name is
Bo yeah I think so I don't know figuring
that out I would say I'm the same as
everybody else just trying to find my
path in life and I think everybody needs
each other to find out who they really
are
so that's it King bubble because I'm the
king of making bubbles
I'm Paul I'm on my way to Palm Springs
to play golf I'm pretty excited soon to
be graduate vegan I'm a tourist in
America for a short while even though I
am from here going back to Japan I'm a
42 year old mother of one of a 20 year
old happy person
ami long young girl lost on a rabbit
hole and a crazy mad world of
destruction of society 36 year old male
in America Mexican American
Texican but I don't consider myself any
religion race or
hatred
I'm a freshman in college I play five
instruments I love dogs and all kinds of
animals I'm half Filipino half white and
I'm five foot two and a half I like the
people tell people I'm five foot three I
have really bad eyesight which is why I
wear glasses but I hate wearing them my
favorite color is blue I love to watch
the show friends on Netflix there's one
animal that I hate I'd probably say it's
spiders I don't have a kind of music
that I like but I just it depends on my
mood I guess I like go from classical to
like hard rock in a matter of seconds
I'm usually really quiet and I really
like talking to people but I usually
make an exception there people who seem
nice and cool
[Music]
how much like he's going for guys my
name is Mariah and I'm the owner of this
channel I'm also the person behind the
camera and I thought I'd take a minute
to thank all the subscribers I gained so
far and maybe asking new year's to the
subscribe button if you liked this
episode or if you're a fan of my channel
in general a lot thank you